I left before it ended. I
was at a friend's party and
went to a Superbowl party.
It was fun. The lowest viewed one in the
last 10 years. Are you serious? Yeah,
but not by a lot,
but yeah,
it's cause they knew that that handsome
man was going to take your shirt off.
Oh God. His name Adam Levine.
That's beautiful. Mass.
No nipples or everyone's time as Nicholas.
Now he has nice Brown nipples,
but then we're like Janet Jackson,
like the big crazy.
He loved shows, nipples.
Both. This is bullshit. Sexist
bullshit. And his Dick Route.
This is, oh my God. He had dick
route showing God is bullshit.
He just wanted everybody know he's got
beautiful tattoos and a fairly good body.
Yeah. He does a lot of squats though.
Right? That's what's interesting.
He's around like the greatest super
athletes in the known universe. Actually.
Looks pretty good right there. Oh,
for today he was, it was pretty good.
Those random for today was,
I mean,
he's not always around the greatest super
athletes, right? No, no. Yeah, yeah. Um,
yeah. It looks pretty good. He
looks like he's in good shape.
Happy to take your shirt off with
his California stomach tattoo.
But the point being
that guys around freaks,
he's around six foot, five, 290 pounds,
super athletes who could
jump over his fucking head.
They literally could run through a
hundred of him like they were paper walls,
just raw.
That's what he's around.
He's around the fucking super bowl,
the greatest physical specimens
in the known universe.
And he takes his shirt off
like, hey bitches, I'm here too.
They had an event set up over the weekend.
Uh, so people can test their 40 speed,
uh, up against other NFL times, whatever
they had. Like, oh, that's hilarious.
Hussein bolt did it and it's in his
shoes. They said street shoes, whatever.
But he didn't have cleats on. He
tied the fastest ever. NFL 40.
He's probably dealing with a full stomach.
He probably just eight track a
couple of beers. Fuck it. I'll,
I'll show these bitches.
What's up? Yeah, it's just,
it was weird, like watched it on TV. Do
with a shirt off, you know, like, oh,
this is a different thing now. Now,
this is like a sexy concert for,
it was like a football.
That's what I think he's getting shit
for it because he didn't need to take a
shirt off. Right. You know,
he had his shirt on and then like after
it is second songs, like you know what,
let's get sexy and this Superbowl
bowl. No, no. But I mean,
why else would he take off this shirt?
I mean, at least make it a Hashtag.
Hashtag sexy in the Superbowl.
It's getting sexy up in this bitch.
Well, he's a sexy man. Can't, don't be
hating. Beautiful Man. Yeah, I mean, but,
but that's the whole thing. You're,
you're audience is a bunch of guys.
You know my jacket on, I'm sorry with Jack
and on. Well, it was cold out at first,
but then he started to
warm up a sweat cow.
Never trust white men with Nicholas's.
That's my message now.
He's got the little necklaces and the
bracelets for the Falcons to land on.
Wait a minute.
Those are spiritual necklaces.
If you have wooden beads for whatever
reason that makes you spiritual or gold.
I can't even tell you allowed to wear
wooden deck assists cause like people go,
oh, you're like really endorse
organic stuff. He really into macro,
but that's gold is gold.
That's like the other one was just weird
lighting. I can, I can't wear necklaces,
man. It, it bugs me. Did you ever
wear necklaces? Necklaces? Sure. Yeah.
It's never been a staple, but it's
a, it's a, it's a weird thing if,
first of all, if it's, if it's big
enough, it's like this target, right?
If you have like a bail gold necklace,
people want to steal it. All right.
There's a lot of necklace
snatchers out there, Brian.
I don't know if you know that. Yeah.
But then the other thing is like,
what are you doing?
What are you doing with that big
old shiny thing around your neck?
What are you doing?
What do you a chick remember in the
nineties chokers worry thing and I used to
wear a choker. How gross
is that? Like a dog choker?
It's just a really tight
necklace. Yeah. Hemp necklaces.
Oh yeah, those were the little bead. The
bead at the bottom. The beads critical.
Got To have the bead. Yeah, multi
colored bead thinking. Look, your cool.
Yeah,
like it's weird like with like some guys
will wear like little anklets with like
beads. Can they tie them off and they'll
walk around barefoot and you're like,
okay, hmm. What's kind of like that?
Look that that you're not shop.
Look where you have like the really tight,
like your pants to go up
so you can see your socks.
You know you show a little leg. You
know why they do that? Why sneakers?
Those gods show off the sneakers up
full snake. That's what shop told me.
Do you do that Jeremy? That's what my,
my pants have that actually for you.
That's how the pants. Ah, that's
funny. That's how the pants are made.
That's why you don't buy those pants,
man. That then you're not buying pants.
Where do you ladies store? Do
you buy? Do you buy it at coach?
Do you buy those pants and Ky.
Dot Count. Gosh, that's hilarious.
You don't do that too. You know
how dare you? How dare you.
I'm pair of a very comfortable
underarmor running shoes on.
How are those trouble cause
your shoes the other day? Um,
they're a little too tight for me. Okay.
They live, they bind my feet a tad bit.
When I got to the store, I
had to swap them out for a,
I had a pair of a converse.
All Stars would, you might
go to, you got Yeezys right.
Jamie gave me a pair of Yeezys about
a year ago and he just wore him.
Talk to him. You just keeping
them on ice dead socked him.
Is that what's called that
stock dead stock. Dead stock.